i have another one of these
kind of dystopian
uh stories about my interactions with
the medical system uh many of you will
remember my infamous 35 40 000
appendectomy from a couple of years back
i have a new one guys i had a freckle
removed
and we're talking about 2 300 so here's
what what went on
um i had i have various freckles and
moles like many people do i'm not going
to list where every single one of them
is but
all sorts of different places
and i had one on my abdomen
it just looked a little bit different it
had a little bit of a glow around it
um it had like a little black dot and
what was otherwise about okay well
listen i don't need to describe to you
the the
exact the dermatological characteristics
but i said
uh i'm gonna have this one looked at so
i went to my dermatologist and i said to
him sir what do you think and he looked
at it and he said it's probably fine
let's put it under a black light
i forget what that's called but he did
that he said the black light stuff it
also seems fine but you know we can't
really be sure unless
we do a biopsy do you think you want a
biopsy and i said oh boy i don't know i
did not big on medical procedures what's
the biopsy he says little shot of uh
numbing
and then i take this thing called a
biopsy punch looks like a hole punch and
we'll just punch out a two millimeter
little circle we'll send it out to be
looked at is it
do you think medically it's appropriate
he said listen my view is
um
when your attention goes to a particular
freckle or mole
it might be for a reason
so
we'll get information let's do it i said
fine numb me up give me the whole thing
we did it
i have a i have pretty crappy insurance
because as a self-employed individual
i'm in the private market private market
plans are just terrible i pay 543
dollars a month
and i still have a 60 copay for
specialists and i still have a 2 000
deductible for um
analysis of any kind
so
he does the biopsy and i hear back it's
benign it's benign it's nothing let's
just see if it comes back we'll keep an
eye on it but it's benign no need to
worry great well i i know i'm gonna get
a bill for my 60
copay
first bill comes in and i'm putting
these up on the screen for you guys
first bill
is for 631
dollars whoa wait hold on
where did this come from well
i had in my office visit so they charged
for that
i had the biopsy that was 204
okay
and then there was the lab pathology
that needed to be done you can't just do
the biopsy you've got to study the
biopsy so that's 100 another 159 bucks
so now it's 6 31.
my insurance covered about half leaving
three hundred dollars for me so i've got
my sixty dollar copay but some of this
stuff
is not part of the office visit it's
extra
so i owed 307
and i thought okay well that's not that
bad
but wait a second what about the
facility i mean guys they've got to keep
the lights on the temperature was
pleasant in the room
so i've got to pay for the facility
but also i need to pay for the procedure
itself
i don't even know what i mean i thought
i already did so that's another
eleven hundred fifty dollars but not to
worry
my insurance company has covered
510 dollars leaving only another 639 for
me
now you want to know the sick reality
before i total all of this up for you
guys
part of what the insurance covered
they didn't actually pay
it's that my insurance negotiated a
discount
so even though it shows up that my
insurance covered five hundred and ten
dollars of one piece and three hundred
and twenty dollars of the other piece
they didn't really cover eight hundred
dollars
uh more than half of that was they thank
god they did this for me aren't they
nice they negotiated a discount
with my insurance company so at the end
of the day
a five-minute biopsy
ends up with me owing
for the month
1489.
it's i'm already in for 543 on my health
insurance and then i owe another
940
for the biopsy
am i better off not having insurance is
a really fair question there's this
whole cycle that happens and we've
talked about the broken nature of this
system not everybody pays
and insurance companies negotiate
discounts so this creates a race to the
bottom really a race to the top where
the providers keep bumping up
the prices that they bill to insurance
knowing that insurance is going to come
to them and say we don't want to pay
that much we want to pay less so give us
a discount and then knowing that some
people won't have insurance and they'll
end up not paying at all and they'll
have to write off some of that so they
have to raise the price even more to
account for some people aren't going to
pay maybe they really should only be
charging 300 for this total but between
insurance and medical billing and
overhead and negotiated discounts it
goes up up up up
so at the end of the day
if i didn't even have insurance it's
conceivable that i could have gone to
them and said guys
do you have a cash price
because i have no insurance
i would have saved my 540 a month in
premium and maybe they would have said
we will accept
x or we will accept y or some some
smaller amount obviously the risk with
that is if you have something really
major 250 000 500 000
you know icu stays really really bad
even the cash discount is not going to
be affordable so just another this is
not unique this is a very small thing i
know many of you in the audience have
emailed sengu you've got hundreds of
thousands of dollars a month in bills
because you're on expensive medications
or require expensive treatments etcetera
i am just giving you a tiny little
example this was the smallest skin
biopsy that could be done the two
millimeter they call it the little boy
uh it wasn't the you don't you don't
want to see the big boy when they have
to do the big boy and we're talking
about
total
2 300
of which i end up paying nine something
plus my health insurance premium it's
not a sustainable system
and by the way i can afford this
right at the end of the day
this 950 i i can afford it it's painful
yeah i mean it's frustrating but i can
afford it
40 of the country
can't meet an unexpected 400 expense
without
going into debt
i went in thinking i have a 60 copay
when there the doctor says the
appropriate thing
is to do a biopsy what i'm going to say
no and all of a sudden i come out owing
9.50
in addition to my health insurance
premium it's a crazy system and i know
that i will get emails from people
around the country saying around the
world rather saying
david that system in the u.s is nuts we
know it's nuts trust me we know it's
nuts